welcome back to
the second
live ep that we are driving here
forgot what we're gonna be talking about
one of the brothers can remind me about
that in a quick second but
how's everyone doing today we're gonna
give it a little
bit of time here before we get into the
ep every like a minute maybe two i'm the
la bro could be better this uh really
gloomy weather in
toronto been raining lately
[Music]
elbow injury season two i've heard
yes yes yes
man just getting hit with one thing
after another alhamdulillah
you're not injured though
no it's i wouldn't no no it's it's far
far from injury information
yeah yeah yeah you know the thing when
you like you look up your sentence on
google and it gives you a long scary
name yeah and you're like what bag is
that yeah i got some like rust
busted
thing
and i'm like bro what the heck but yeah
i over trained way way probably just or
bro
yeah and then it's like
the normal soreness can you have normal
soreness on top of domes
on top of what
delay don't say muscles you can if
you're like a complete like noob
yeah
wrong and i'm not calling him a noob but
like you you took in a big break
yeah
that usually happens like if you go too
hard too soon
yeah just ridiculously soft for no
reason
yeah yeah so aside from uh all this man
we got a we had a good week
right good feedback good videos
so a lot has changed guys we uh
we've had the
utmost honor
through the grace of allah to speak to
us
one of the most prominent figures in
the youtube scene
so
expect some uh lit episodes coming up
shortly there were a lot of gems
yeah
well a lot of gems started to win
i mean bro why don't you two tell me
one thing that sticks
in your minds
that you learned from the episodes that
we did bro too much
too much
there's no one noteworthy thing
um all noteworthy man it is bro but like
i guess something a few notes that i
took in my head was uh number one
i gotta do cardio
i definitely gotta start getting cardio
more um yeah
number two
he kind of
for not kind of he really did clarify
and
uh because in one of his podcasts he was
talking about how
um you know when you're training it
should be fun you know you should
you should always stop before you're
exhausted so that way you can go back in
the next day and then keep training and
then you can progressively go further
and further and further
and that increases workload over time
but i always wondered like how does that
really look like
in brazilian jiu jitsu and
though he
he didn't exactly elaborate on
that he went into a different example
um
[Music]
uh
it's uh i'd say it was
it kind of like the example he was
giving just kind of made sense that he
did say at the end was like you know
when when you're doing mma
um the moment you start becoming like
sluggish the moment you start feeling
like you just have no energy take that
break and if you feel like the energy
comes back maybe go in again and if you
feel like it doesn't all right leave it
there
and he gave the analogy of um
the example of basketball where it's
like if you're shooting hoops and you're
making all the shots like he's gonna let
you keep shooting he's not gonna stop
you but then the moment that you start
dipping down where it's like let's say
out of ten shots in the beginning you
were making like nine out of ten well
now let's say you you're dipping down to
like six out of ten he's okay well now
it's done
if you continue now it's just gonna it's
gonna
you basically implementing
a uh a bad pattern
you know because uh it's not practice
makes perfect it's perfect practice
makes perfect so if you're doing
bad practice then you are just
reinforcing bad behavior you know this
is way more but like that's
the gems
yeah yeah and
for air
how about yourself
and before you go real quick to all the
viewers that made it this far please
check out the shorts that i dropped
today it's a little bit of like a teaser
trailer i think rami already saw it i
put it on tik tok as well it's uh for
the upcoming
episodes we got with brother for us
how about you
yeah
so i don't
i want to give two answers so i don't
give a generic he said this and it stood
out and i want to give uh
just just his his character
who he is really
yeah bro because my answer would have
been the character but i don't i don't
know if we're thinking the same thing
but i'll let you go first
obviously so bro the his character and
him as a father you know i looked at him
like masha'allah that's a good father
that's a good family man you're good of
course he's gonna say the same thing man
no it's just it's the little pauses
every now and then uh guys can you wait
let me check on my my daughter make sure
she came home let me check on my son
make sure he's at the bus stop he didn't
say it but it just it went through his
actions how much he cares as a father
yeah
in the story he told about his son when
he went to school
tea and biscuits
every week like clockwork hello listen
exactly
live so yeah that was my first time my
second answer is is the whole
uh topic of basically identity and
existence and if a robot romney who acts
like rami is you know as a robot
and he dies is that you know
do we lose romney basically is he dead
um was that romney was it not rami and
and all that stuff and the whole topic
of
um basically all your ideas are are
basically conjugations of things you've
seen and you've things you've observed
and taking it a step further
to his argument
god cannot be observed therefore we
shouldn't even have any idea of god
nothing even close to god not nothing
even comparable to god could be observed
so god would be the greatest idea any
man could ever have
because it's like there's power imagine
the an all-powerful being there's
knowledge imagine an all-knowing be and
then combines all these these attributes
into one
being
if it wasn't in us it would be the most
absurd idea the most complex idea a man
basically could ever have
that's that's crazy
there were a lot of uh mind benders
with him so
yeah look forward to that guys
there's a 61 viewers right now so we
should have 61 likes please get the
likes up and for those of you that are
catching the stream after it's already
been broadcasted what are you doing man
show up on time next time inshallah
or
just smash the like button right now to
make up for it if we get a thousand
likes on this video i will drop a longer
trailer on sunday insha'allah for you
guys
with brother feras
aside from all that i think we should go
into the meat of the episode what do you
guys think
all
right get it let's get it let's get it
all right so
we've been getting a lot of dms since we
started this channel on people asking
generic inquiries and questions and
you know they want fatwas too we can't
always give that but you know it is what
it is yeah uh let me quickly
god lives
all right okay
we got a little bit before we even get
that let's let's kind of elaborate like
what we're going into okay so we've been
getting a lot of dm's as i have
mentioned just now um about various
things thought was too we're not really
qualified for that but things that we
could help you on a journey from
experience we do our part inshallah we
do our best um
however that being said lately we've
been getting a lot of
uh
dms from sisters specifically that are
asking what should we be like what do
men like what do men find desirable in
in wives
in long-term marriages and
sustainability what makes men
look at us as red flags or what are red
flags that might come up you know in the
pre nikkah or post nikah stuff like that
so you know i've been thinking i'm like
we've been making a lot of videos for
the brothers
alhamdulillah but we should all make a
video with
you know the three of us about sisters
and kind of put them on game about what
men really look for
and again we could speak anecdotally so
that's what we're going to do we're
going to speak on behalf of us and
ourselves
and maybe personal experience or at
least desires
and i guess green flags red flags
whatever you want to call it however
we're still gonna uh
talk about the polls that we did so on
instagram stories if you're not
following us on three muslims the three
muslims follow us now
we post a lot of updates there i put up
a question
for one women saying uh
if you uh
are looking for marriage or you're
currently married what do you think you
bring to the table of like actual value
so ask that question and i also asked a
question uh for women for the sisters
what do you think men look for
and alhamdulillah we got a lot of
responses that rami is going to read out
um aside from that i also asked two
questions for the brothers number one
for the bros
what are red flags for women and number
two
what are things that you absolutely love
about women things you look out for
so yeah we don't want to just speak from
our anecdotal experience we also want to
you know share these polls so inshallah
that's what this episode is going to be
about
okay we got a question from ai again
exactly i wanted to ask you what is a
high value woman to a
man what was the thing that uh i said
before
to answer your question i would bring to
my husband respect peace
comfort support martial
all right
you already halfway
we'll talk about a lot of stuff so
angel do you want to answer this uh
this question first
for you specifically
[Music]
why you gotta put me on the spot bro
y'all are married or one of you is
something that's why you y'all closer
so if we answer it kind of makes no
difference bro cause you're looking the
most
all right what
sense
okay what what do i see personally as a
high-value woman
high-value woman number one
and this has been evolving
so this may change over time
a lot of them but number one is dean
she's gotta be on dean if she's not on
dean
uh
i'm just not even
i'm gonna waste my time because
listen you could be attractive
you can know how to cook we could
connect and all that stuff but if you
don't have bean then
i can't trust your judgment i can't
trust your loyalty i can't trust you
period
because you don't even have that dark
white you don't have that fear of allah
how can i put my trust in someone that
doesn't have of about
you know so that's number one that's
that's a high value thing do you guys
want me to continue or do you want me to
leave it at that time
uh
so on top of that that has to be
connection
so chemistry
right like i'm not asking the woman to
be perfect because i understand nobody
is perfect i myself am not perfect i
have issues as well so i don't mind if
the girl has issues
as long as we are both striving to be
better every single day but there has to
be
that chemistry that has to be connection
i'm not just going to be with someone
or actually i'm over here saying what i
i would want i'm talking about high
high value yeah so um
disregard that because that's that's
more like what am i looking for in a
woman
instead of talking about high volume i
say another thing for high value she has
to have personality yeah
and then she has to be able to cook on
just because
i really like food
so when a woman cooks it just
it just changes everything and there is
that one saying where it's like the way
to a man's heart is his stomach
that that's mine
you're looking for a sister that can
that can cook some mean uh lamb chops
but for you hello obviously
bro if she includes a lamb chops she can
cook the curries you can cook that
garlic naan bread nah listen i ain't
gonna be eating this all the time i like
simple i like eating very simple and
then eating
complex every now and then but
she can whip it up boy that's that's
high value in mine is she capable of
whipping it up that's it exactly exactly
all right tell you bro
uh brother rami what in your eyes is a
high value woman
to a man you can give a
kind of a generic answer as to like what
you think
makes the woman high value
herself or you can give an intrinsic one
to you what you find high value
all right
i'm going to be as
brutally honest as possible all right to
be honest
that's all we ask for right
so
looks 100 percent matter
to a man
why do we lose 30 viewers no i'm just
playing
filtering out the uh the fake inshallah
but men 100 percent care about looks
it's not the same when a woman looks
like uh looks at a man you know as when
a man looks at a woman looks to matter
and it is subjective so just like women
are going to find some men attractive
some and ugly men are going to find some
women attractive and some women not as
attractive and the reason i didn't say
ugly is because i honestly think all
women are actually beautiful because
allah has put this type of beauty in
women
that i just think
it's feminine generally yeah the
feminine feminine beauty that just men
don't have but again i'm a mess maybe
i'm being subjective but regardless
um that's just in terms of looks and i'm
assuming you guys know character indeed
i'm just going to assume that because
you guys should know that character at
least bare minimum or sorry dean at
least bare minimum and in character i
want to talk a little more about that so
the character a woman should have is
just look at the the wives of the
prophet
look at samaya
when she comforted the prophet islam
and morally supported him
where you know she she would keep the
house tidy for him the kids quiet when
they played
um she would have food ready like all
these things things that made his life
easy
because the the woman is honestly i know
she comes from the rib of the man but
she's truly the backbone of the man
because for every great man that you
have you have a woman
that's that's basically in the back
supporting him and that's not to say
that all women are in the back women in
the kitchen that's to say that that
women are not supposed to be on the
front lines like men men are supposed to
be front line war front line dow a front
line you know there are women who go and
do that as well 100
but i'm saying it's the man's obligation
to do that so a man is going to look for
a woman who can emotionally support him
that can uh support him in in any way
even if it's in the sense that she she
you know she has
you know financial capabilities herself
so she takes care of herself i'm not
saying men look for that
but even things like that add to it my
point is that you support the man and
it comes in the form of
comfort
and and having wisdom and all of that
and and men want a woman i know it might
sound backwards but men want a woman
who's capable
right and i don't mean capable of like
fixing the garage or something i mean
capable of
you know basically living her life
uh in a sense that whenever something
comes up she can handle it you know what
i mean
not in a way we're like oh i'm
independent i can do whatever i want
uh but in the way that you know
something comes up she doesn't always
have to go to someone else to come to
you or something about it but last thing
i want to say before i forget but i
didn't already forget
no i stuck my mind by i'm done
no worries
bro for your uh your feedback and your
input on that
to answer yes question myself i would
say that what makes a woman high value
to a man
is going to differ and depend on the man
right so
we are focused here specifically on
muslim
men right we're not focused on
non-muslim kuffar men
i'm sure we'll differ right if we ask
non-muslim men it would be
from my understanding more superficial
things there's a whole dating culture
relationships one night stand so on and
so forth
and i'm sure there's some non-muslims
that are out here looking for pious
women too
but i'm just going based off personal
observations
for muslim men i think predominantly
aside from different on the man i think
that objectively speaking we should be
putting dean forward
obviously as brother angel said
um and then after that i always ask men
this question
when they have
a p addiction you know watching and you
know all that or anything like that i'm
just like the women that you guys are
looking at or objectifying or whatever
could you like could you ever look at
her as the mother of your kids
and nine times out of nine they're like
hell no i'm just like why are you
watching them then you know what i mean
it just it just quickly changes a
paradigm in their eyes
but
let me say just look at every single
woman that you would want to potentially
be willing to marry and ask yourself
would you want them to be the mother of
your kids would you want your daughter
to be like this
if the question is yes then you already
know what you like
me personally it would be
uh it is this quote kind of when romney
was talking about capable there's a
quote that men should be capable and
women should be coachable
this isn't some spin on you know
anything misogynistic i'm just saying
like a woman who is obedient and she
wants to please her husband that's a
quality woman
and it's really hard to find today and
likewise a man should be pleasing his
wife too
so i would say obedience
loyalty and loyalty is not just what
you're doing when i'm here it's what
you're doing behind my back
um prophet sallam said two of the most
important or most difficult things for
us the biggest fitness for us so what's
between our lips and what's between our
legs
between our lips meaning that jihad for
having haya in our speech
and not saying too much not being harsh
with others unnecessarily not cursing
profanity that type of stuff
and what's between our legs is you guys
already know
we got general sound in the building
would you say men should be what
men should be capable women should be
coachable
i can see that now
aside from everything else that i've
mentioned i would say that what makes a
woman additionally high value to you
is
just how down she is how down for the
cause she is how down she is for your
program
it's like when you have an idea or you
want to
start a new project or you want to
change your life and make hijra or move
or anything
how supportive is she with you how how
with you is she for that cause without
asking about the little vicissitudes and
like okay how is this going to happen
how is that going to happen how am i
going to do this how am i going to do
that like how willing is she for your
cause
and i think that's a strong
covert indicator of how good of a mother
she will be because i think being a
mother is one of the hardest if not the
hottest jobs out here it's a full-time
job 24-7 no days off no breaks
and most mothers from what i've seen
take the job seriously
yeah they might complain here and there
or they might be married to husbands
that are not doing their end of the
bargain but it really is a huge
responsibility
and the woman has to be capable as well
exactly exactly so
my advice to
ladies
if you have some
issues that and we all know what issues
we have i'll either talk about it in our
episode
any issues that you feel like you have
something you're doing that you
shouldn't be doing or something you need
to improve
you've got time if you're single if you
don't
you know make dua may allah make it easy
for you if you're a man i would say my
best advice is
pick a good woman to begin with instead
of trying to change a woman to become
better for you it's so much easier to
meet a woman who meets like 99 of your
your traits or qualifications than to
change a woman who doesn't
that being said there's a lot of nuances
because people change sometimes
and jeez bro we've been live for almost
25 minutes now
no
i swear voila it feels like it's only
been like two two to five minutes that's
going before before we even get on that
to sum it up like it's three things
we'll make it sooner here three things
that a woman can do
that will make her high value it's the
man to the man that she can attract uh
number one beyond thee sorry
get on dean number two
character
right
be the best person you can be it's very
simple
and then number three
is
beautify yourself
doesn't mean cake up doesn't mean be
like these little
dolls where you completely change how
you look and you look like
you're an older person or just a
completely different woman no no just
beautify yourself
the way that
you know in a very simple
way because obviously a lot loves
that which is beautiful
and when you beautify yourself you just
like like romney said you know as males
we
tend to function with our eyes so
if something is pleasing to our eye
we're probably going to be attracted
and
move towards that all right so
three things very simple
nadeem salaam alaikum brother welcome to
the family
all right so
yeah as being a wife is
uh is hard work that's why a good wife
will be offered to enter from any gate
of paradise she choose yeah uh ladies
like it's very simple like you have all
these ways of pleasing allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala or you could just be a good
wife be obedient to your husband be with
a good man do your part and you can
enter jannah from whatever gate you
choose
to me it's it's like i don't even have
that like opportunity as a man so
i can only go based on what i would do
we got other opportunities and
look at it like this all right we're
coming together in a relationship for
the sake of allah
we're coming together
in a relationship for the sake of our
salvation to complete our deen
and to be able to insha allah make it to
jannah right so if you understand this
then
you're willing to just do your part in
this relationship
where it's like
if a woman or even if a man like if
there's too much pride and arrogance
there where it's like you don't want to
take care of the other person or you
don't want to cook for them or you don't
want to spend money on them you don't
want to do this this and that like
y'all probably shouldn't be together you
should probably take care of your issues
before you actually get with the other
person because
if that's the case
well then two are not coming together
to become one in this communion
right you're not coming together to
complete your dean it's like you're
coming together
for
uh different reasons
and then these things that are
uh not letting you fully connect and do
this for the sake of allah is actually
gonna
i'm not gonna be i'm not the one judging
here i'm not the one that knows the
truth but
if i had a bet i'd bet that it's taking
you away
from being accepted into gender
then bringing you closer to it yeah
true yeah
all right let's see what he wrote let's
admit it y'all
t3m has given much more than five
dollars worth of value let's get more
members insha'allah
i think
i i don't even have to comment on that
like honestly
we uh
we started this for one purpose we still
got the same purpose but the comments do
get a little crazy sometimes so that's
what we turned on members only chat but
uh yeah to all the members we'll open it
up at the end we'll open it okay so
every single live stream thanks for
reminding me on we're gonna open up the
live chat to all subscribers not just
members but subscribers for free and
it'll be like for 10-15 minutes and you
guys can answer ask all your questions
um but that's the thing it's probably
gonna be flooded with questions as usual
and spam and bots and all that so we're
probably only gonna answer a few maybe
like a couple maybe max three to five i
don't know we'll see but uh jazakallah
nadeem once again uh thank you
[Music]
what is your thought about what are your
thoughts about having women uh or women
having beauty intelligence financially
independent and deen as a turn off to
some man okay um again this prefaces my
response initially that it differs from
man to man no two
men are alike and no two women are alike
right but as uh
gabriel al-rahmani commonly says that
being said there are similar
commonalities between men and women that
psychology and just the deen in general
they've been able to i guess
categorize women into right so i would
say that majority of men i can't speak
on majority of men but i can speak on
just myself
and i'll let the other two brothers
answer two uh a woman having beauty i
don't have an issue with that
intelligence i don't have an issue with
that
financially independent okay
we'll talk about that and then as i turn
off okay i don't see why
three of these would be an issue
right
financially independent here's the thing
i want a woman to be able to be
financially independent
so in the sense that if something
happens to me she knows how to make a
living ideally ideally but if you look
at islam it never makes women
responsible in that sense she always has
a wali either it's going to be her man
her husband if he passes away her father
right and before marriage obviously her
father
she's always supposed to be taken care
of which alhamdulillah
but if something happens to me i still
want to know that this world is tough
and a lot of men can't even support
their their daughters let alone
after a divorce even before the before
the marriage they can support i would
say that uh
financially independent that you know
how to make a living
it's something that it's like something
in the back of your pocket it's like a
tool whether it be a skill or something
that you could take out
i do think that personally speaking a
woman who is focusing on the family is
much better aligned with the fitra and
things are just much more easy for her
um it being a turn off it depends see if
she is interdependent i don't have an
issue with that right
independence is to say that i don't need
you i got myself
she's not really in a frame but that's
just me what about you too
you want to go first on huh
yeah so
i'ma agree with you
and i'm gonna add here like the beauty
intelligence financial independence the
dean
these are all great things like fire
said it should be financially
interdependent meaning that like look i
can
make my own money here but i recognize
the value
within this other person here
that's how it always should be we should
never
think of ourselves as like truly
independent because we never really are
if you think about it
excuse me
uh but beauty obviously like i said
beautify yourself
all right every woman is uh
just gonna look different
and every man is gonna be attracted to
different women
all right so like you beautify yourself
and again don't try to cake up don't try
to make yourself into someone completely
different just
do the things that accentuate your
features that allah has given you and
then just keep it simple
right but intelligence like me
personally i i want a girl that knows
but like does she have to be the the
most intelligent woman in this world in
terms of like
having master's degrees and doing stuff
no she doesn't
now if if that's something that she
fancies
by all means
if we connect on all the other values
i don't see that being a a
problem here and now the the financial
thing
i don't need to go to be financially
independent
i just need her to be capable
of doing that like fire said if
something happens
i want to know that she can
be able to uh
take care of that because like my mom
when she was a voice and she was going
to other stuff like
she made use
of the money that she had to support me
and my sister
and like when i what i saw her go
through and what i saw her do for us
showed me how resourceful she was
with this money right but when she was
married
she was not being
that resourceful as she was
in that situation she was not being as
independent but financially independent
as she was in that situation when
you get what i'm saying here so like
the woman has to be capable that's all
she doesn't have to be financially
independent she just has to be capable
of handling her own if something
god forbid were to go down and obviously
dean you know like that's that's a given
that should be the first one
for signing up may allah bless you
immensely and welcome to the family
all right
i'm going to let you uh answer this
question
uh as soon as we address this why
alaikum assalamu
so um i want to remove dean from the the
list completely i don't know any man
who's going to see dean of the turn off
and if he sees that as a turn of the
entire person stay away because if
someone doesn't like dean brothers the
worst of the worst i'll protect us from
that
um
i i wouldn't differentiate between
beauty intelligence and and financial
independence maybe i would remove beauty
from the category because every man
loves beauty and if a man is like turned
off by beauty and maybe he's a little
intimidated by the woman because maybe
he's a little insecure about himself
he's like oh she's a beautiful woman
well what if i you know can't handle
talking to her what if i mess up
other than that it's not that big of a
deal it's not really a turn off maybe a
bit
of an insecurity
when it comes to
financially independent and intelligent
uh for some men there is a bit of
intimidation with that jordan pearson
talks a lot about how every time a
woman's iq goes up by 16 points uh or
goes up by a few points she's 16 less
likely
uh
to marry someone meaning that the
[ __ ] of people she can marry is
smaller and smaller
and basically because men
like to marry
women who i guess are intelligent as
intelligent as them maybe aren't as
capable of them would as jordan peterson
says are further down on the the
hierarchy when it comes to
um status or whatever in society um and
likewise women marry up
so um i wouldn't say to turn off but it
does sometimes deter men i would say
because the stigma that these women are
very disagreeable that they're going to
try and be in charge they're going to
this that the other for both
intelligence and financial stability uh
or independence whatever you want to
call it and i don't like i don't want to
use the term financially independent
because that kind of implies that she
will be in the marriage but islamically
as the brothers mentioned
the man is obligated to provide at least
a bare minimum
um so if anything i think it would be a
benefit that she has some kind of income
or something as long as it doesn't take
her away from your marriage like if it's
a source of passive income what's wrong
with that i would think that's amazing
actually because then as a man you can
cover the bare minimum the basics to
everything you know she needs and if she
wants to
if she wants to go out of her way and
buy you know extra this style and
whatever she can go ahead and do that
it's not a problem it's a money found
issue and when the money's not an issue
alhamdulillah
um you know a lot of the the problems in
your marriage might fade because a lot
of couples
basically you know
mess up because of money issues nowadays
unfortunately
[Music]
so me personally like
the the marriage that i'm in right now
with my wife
whenever we we do stuff like sometimes
when we go to the movies or you know
normal stuff like that
she'll just get popcorn or she'll get
the tickets like things like this it's
like what you're saying you know that
little passive income side hustle income
cool but in terms of
all household expenses like rent
food bills
this type of stuff it's on every man to
be able to pay
and notice that i said to be able to pay
if your wife wants to help out with that
i don't think it's an issue with that
but you should be you you let your wife
get butter on the popcorn
uh yeah cause i'm not eating it anyway
bro i hate popcorn
i hate popcorn bro i'm like the only guy
that doesn't like popcorn bro
yeah you just don't like how like
nutritionally void it is
yeah i think it's a scam too bro because
like the amount of popcorn or not the
amount of popcorn what am i saying the
amount of time that
is spent in the movie from the admission
time until when the trailers are done
playing i'm done like when i was a kid i
would eat popcorn i'd be down like call
my popcorn before the movie even started
so i don't know what that what's up with
that but continue though finish
finishing point yeah so bro that's more
let's say man i already said what i had
to say um
a man should be capable of covering 100
percent of basic necessities and
household expenses if your woman wants
to help you out with that alhamdulillah
if she doesn't you better be able to
cover and if you're not i don't think
you're ready for marriage um but there's
a lot of parents that i'm speaking to
right now that are definitely tuning in
currently
almost 150 viewers parents make it easy
for your kids to get married what are
you doing this whole you know i'm gonna
send them off to university uh you know
single
in their sexual peak at age 18.
fertility peak at age 18
and you're gonna have to put your head
down and get that degree for four years
and i can go uh you know into bed with
my wife at night so you know that's not
my problem sucks
like what are you what are you talking
about as a father as a mother like it's
your job to make
lives easy for your kids
and intimacy is a big part and
i feel like a lot of this is this is
something i see in in desi households
right i was speaking to my cousin last
week and we were talking about how in
desi cultures and a lot of you know
south asian asian cultures maybe in
middle eastern too
kids don't witness too much intimacy
from their parents because it's a little
taboo right i understand that islam
doesn't shy away from intimacy guys you
know kitab
we're not going to talk about that
islam doesn't culture taboos uh you know
intimacy
because of this parents don't even you
know
hug or or even show you know in front of
their kids that
the dad even likes the mom or the mom
even likes the dad so because of this
kids are shamed and repressed in terms
of their sexuality from a really young
age at least in the halal way
so
when they get a little ounce of freedom
they either go completely berserk and
hypersexual and fall into haram or they
become asexual and they don't know how
to even deal with these things so i
think those are two extremes and these
two happen these do happen so parents
make it easy for your kids
i mean
bro and let me just add on to the point
that romney was saying about
intelligence
wrong bro
it's very simple
right because a lot of women will get
you know triggered by this and say oh
you don't wanna intelligent woman no no
listen it's very simple
when an individual
increases themselves in knowledge
the conversations that they have the
interactions they have the way that they
express themselves it all changes
from this knowledge so
if someone becomes more intelligent
their
their sense of humor is going to change
the personality is going to change the
way they interact is going to change now
that's not always a bad thing
could be good
could be good could be bad depending on
the individual and how they want to do
this but
it's going to change the way that you
interact with this person
this person even if they are also
intelligent
let's say okay let's say you have an
example you have this guy
intelligent guy mashallah and then you
have this woman very intelligent woman
marshall
went to school has masters two masters
by the way not just one two master's
degree
and she's a bookworm she's always in
there studying studying studying doing
all this stuff listen they start having
conversation together
they're not really going to connect
because
in terms of intellect in terms of all
that she's on a different level than he
is so therefore because there's no
connection
nothing happens with them
so that's why jordan peterson says when
a woman becomes more intelligent she
starts getting to this level her pull
becomes smaller and smaller because
i hate to say this but there are not
many men out there that are constantly
increasing
their intelligence
like that yes you know there are men who
self-improve yes there are men who
are academic and they're constantly
learning more and more but even then the
pool is small for them
the pool of men who do this is small so
therefore if you're a woman and you
start doing this your pool also becomes
small
so it's not to say don't seek
intelligence
but it's like you have to put it into
what's worth having in this life like if
you truly value intelligence
by all means go after
by all means i'm not saying not to i'm
just saying except the reality that by
doing so you will limit the pool
you know it it's it's called
the uh cost of opportunity when you win
somewhere you lose somewhere else and
that's to go with everything in life
mm-hmm and guys we got a lot of
questions so we're going to go ahead and
in a second but what is educated what is
intelligence like if if a woman brings
to the table
education islamic knowledge
this will definitely add to her case
because i want that i want you to be
able to teach my kids the dean alongside
myself
if you're bringing in mathematical
knowledge let's say of course i want you
i don't want kids being
you know needing help in math and we
don't know how to help them i'm busy
providing you're out here let's say you
can't help them and then they end up
failing school and not pursuing their
dreams right so at the end of the day
they're equally important but uh it
differs from man to man man to woman
and from woman to man uh angel in terms
of what you were saying and rami what
you saying about jordan peterson
hypergamy is a real thing bro um
mohammed talked about in the debate
hypergamy isn't
i guess relevant to 100 of women
some prioritize stuff like homogamy and
stuff like that which are like more
similarities that they have but
hypergamy is a real thing women on
average do want men that are making more
than them right this is this has been
proven in every single study thus far
um
all other variables being the same uh
men that are higher status and all that
so at the end of the day women really do
like men that are more intelligent than
them so
you look at the two ways you can look at
that men are not really
like the average man is not
too good today you know what i mean
so women really don't have much to
choose from anyway
but at the end of the day i feel like if
you're a woman watching this
don't think that
being intelligence being intelligent is
a is a turn off for men
um
you know but also don't think it's it's
like the only thing don't think it's
something we care about like don't think
it's something we prioritize above all
else
you know so we need to find that balance
i hate i hate being black and white all
right calabash could it be the other way
around that highly intelligent women
do not find less intelligent men
attractive instead of men being
intimidated
that's kind of what i said yeah
yeah it could definitely be the case um
and i think it boils down to
women women i believe they want to
admire their men they want to respect
them and they want to look up to him and
be like you know that's my man you know
in a very admirable way
um and having
if you're better than your man in xyz
you can't really admire him in xyz right
like if i'm like lebron james i can't
really admire
you know basketball players like i can
respect them i can't appreciate that but
it's not going to be admiration i'm not
going to look up to them the best
doesn't look up to anyone really right
um
and that's why we look up to the process
to them because he was the best right at
least
he took directly from the quran he was
the quran in terms of his character so
when it comes to intelligence if you're
a woman you want to admire your man you
want to respect your man look up to your
man if you're more intelligent than him
then you just can't do that it's not
your fault you just can't and it's just
a natural thing uh so i think it very
much you know could be the case
okay let's go quick because we got a lot
of questions rami i'll leave this to you
bro
um
i mean are we studying arabic i
alhamdulillah i'm going to start soon
insha'allah i did a little bit i took a
break brother brothers fighting on hill
they are alhamdulillah i need tips uh i
would say get a teacher and um
just make it a daily habit even if it's
10-15 minutes a day make a daily habit
learn the alphabet learn certain words
maybe watch movies in arabic i think
that helps as well if it's high audibly
then just go get a teacher get a teacher
okay we did this already ais you're
right or made me restatement you're
right my father always told us to get
education to be able to take care of
ourselves just in case something happens
alhamdulillah i believe from what i'm
hearing your woman your sister so
jazakallah for your input and uh just
know that
this whole
trope of a modern woman
being shamed for depending on a man this
is not islam
we want women to depend on us we want to
feel like we are dependent on it gives a
man purpose in terms of provisioning
oh but even as men like
we still depend on the woman like that's
just how allah made us
it's society it's society that puts it
in our head bro
society puts it in our head for us to be
independent for the man to be
independent and not need the woman it's
like what like bro as the man like allah
said it like he created us in pairs
so the man needs the woman and the woman
he's the man
i agree
i think most financially capable men
don't care about the financial
independence
that's very true
i agree
oh no you were right about intelligence
for a woman
trust me i know women who are highly
educated but they are horrible wives to
their husbands and rude so it doesn't
matter as long as she has deen and is
submissive guys like this whole thing
about
men and women having one thing and then
forgetting the rest it's real
i know men that can recite the entire
quran but they haven't had intimacy with
their wives in a year
like being a multifaceted man or woman
today i don't get it just like angel's
saying like everyone's just convinced to
be one thing instead of another there's
no balance anymore
there's no equilibrium of of of the
sunnah way you look at the prophet saw
everything was in check alhamdulillah
with his life
and there was no one extreme of another
everything was perfectly balanced and i
feel like as men and women we should
strive for that we should never go too
much one way and forget the other what's
the point of studying for your exams for
10 hours and you've missed five you know
prayers of the day
all right we should be
generalists
not specialists
i agree
abdul says there are udemy courses to
learn arabic
okay perfect guys without further ado
let's go right into the poll responses
we're coming to the end here right
i gotta be out of here real soon
perfect bro around me you can start off
with the first question do you mind
reading it up yes
what do you think men find attractive
about women in terms of a wife
and disclaimer women are answering these
questions these are from sisters these
answers are for sisters
yeah
first answer is a good nurturing person
one hundred percent someone who's
nurturing goes back to the whole comfort
and and they get support
um another sister said modesty and how
they hold themselves in public another
very very important one um even with
non-muslims the you know anonymous women
they have the sense of
they're losing it unfortunately but you
know
they have the sense of the sense of you
know i don't want my woman you know my
wife my my girlfriend whatever to be
posting themselves for everyone to see
so great
uh bro i love what you're doing no
disrespect don't take it sideways
we got 500 responses
i'm not gonna read all of them bro
yes
bro i'm not gonna say i don't know anna
left the chat so what i would say is uh
you could read you know some that you
find more interesting
um than that but read as many as you as
you can as you like and we'll go to the
next question when you're ready bro
type
aside from appearance obviously
intelligence humor being confident but
submissive
another sister said
peace beauty agreeable nature and
good potential mother yes those are very
important as well inshallah
beauty respectfulness cooking cleaning
skills and mentality i would say yes
um in today's society it's beauty and a
girl who's fashionable in terms of
clothing and makeup
that's in the forward
yeah yeah yeah i would say for a
phenomenal man yeah so that's that's
important
um
taking on household duties being
obedient to him and looking beautiful
for him yes 100 yes yes i like i like
how she's specified beautiful for him
[Music]
bro i was going to say that too man just
for him like that's a really important
fact that you that the sister put yeah
yeah a lot lesser the responsible
affectionate playful feminine sensual
nurturing pleasant face and body i think
they really summarized it well
in that one
gentleness beauty supportive
another sister says sincerity even if i
make mistakes i want to be sincere in
doing so type that's fair that's fair
sincerity is important
uh if her ego disallows reverence and
respect for her first man he'll never
find peace especially if he's a good man
it's very very pure uh very very true
uh type i'll make the
someone put a very vile answer and i'll
protect this one yeah i know bro it's
like uh i saw that bro let me hear it
bro
no no no well i don't know we can't say
that on there
there's a lot of uh loyalty modesty
warmth femininity right from what i'm
hearing uh rami yeah so it seems like
the sisters got there got this stuff
together for sure in in terms of
thinking what we like
yeah yeah
alhamdulillah they're they're pretty
well underway alhamdulillah and it's
funny because this is not the stuff you
see in in society when it comes to if
you go on the street and ask you know
random i would say non-muslim women it
would be very very different
alhamdulillah i think
generally speaking the last one i'm
going to read femininity
and deen
very important
type so
personally
i think
that's it for this list again the
question
what do you think men
pardon me what do you think men found
attractive
about women in terms of a wife
and the sisters answered
you hear the sisters now we're gonna
we're gonna in a bit speak about the
brothers and we'll see if that really
aligns twinkle twinkle boot jazakallah
for the member comment uh it's nice to
hear from men's perspectives three
muslims are the brothers we all need
they are real may allah bless the three
muslims may allah bless you for blessing
us
[Music]
what is the next question right the next
question is
what do you feel you bring to the table
to offer to a man that he would want
right
um
one person said of our home and children
i'm assuming she meant make the house a
home and then provide children
the same sister later on she said a very
nice body especially with two young
children
uh making dinner and taking care
masha'allah very nice body
yeah she wants the man to have a very
nice body no this is what she brings to
the table she's saying
she she has a nice body for the man to
see basically
a healthy balanced
a healthy balanced tranquility helping
him achieve his dreams goals
to hazard better than one
yeah obedience respect and love
level-headedness uh and being his peace
shyness and an islamic upbringing and
being a homely person
knowing how to cook clean and nurture
the children
being obedient and doing the household
duties uh
one person gave a very depressing
response they said nothing i gave him
everything i had subhan allah
allah protect you
i mean you gotta fix that hurt before
you go around hurting others yeah hurt
people hurt people you heard it here
first
that's facts
next
respect preserving his honor uplifting
him giving him mental and physical
pleasure spiritual harmony
very well said masha allah malicious
said companionship care and love and
i'll make these the last three
having the characteristics to be a good
mother to his kids and being open to
working on myself very very important
may allah bless her
um
and that i love taking care of my family
masha'allah
i forgot to mention men really do love
like a motherly woman not just feminine
but motherly nurturing so it's very
important but there's a difference
there's nurturing yeah
and then there's motherly yeah and when
it comes to the relationship
that the husband and wife should have
the woman should be nurturing not
motherly nurturing yeah
if she becomes if she comes motherly
then it just it destroys the uh the
sexual dynamic yeah 100
100 but if but if uh the relationship is
kind of like fatherly daughterly don't
don't take my words out of context guys
i know someone's going to make a meme
out of this it still works out in terms
of the sexual dynamic
um because as gabriel said in an episode
women can afford to be to be girls is
true yeah but men cannot afford to be
boys in a relationship
yeah so the last one i'm going to read
is support with home and work listening
patience intimacy peace a little fun and
friendship
a very very nice response from the
sisters
guys we got hundreds of responses but
it's we don't have the time to read
through all these but rami gave some
general commonalities that you know we
found through most of the poll responses
okay next question bismillah as a man
what do you find desirable in women as
potential wives all right so
let's see what we got career oriented
too disagreeable
not receptive to male leadership
okay this is uh the next question that i
was reading for red flags so
this is this is definitely not desirable
guys um i was reading the wrong one okay
modesty beauty being femininity pious
women
dean
beauty
a pious peng ting
that's [ __ ]
uh listens willing to be co-pilot
understands a leader and a follower of
beauty
yes since you're supportive loyal
co-pilot um
we'll make a whole separate episode
about that
okay dean and
okay i like that obedience not in a
dominant way just someone who listens
that's key
housewife personality rather than
a hot girl one
okay
modesty religious values and physical
appearance i agree
obedience to allah and his messenger
sallallahu alaihi wasallam this is key
humble
has to be fit and cares about health
okay
cooking cleaning good with kids and most
importantly if she is on her deen i
agree number one dean we got three for
dean
uh in a row feminine respect shyness
and trust
is just something that i feel like when
a woman loses touch with her it's just a
downward slippery slope with other
aspects of her life
from what i've witnessed so
you know and men too like hold on to
your like this is something that
too many people are just shameless today
dean personality looks we got cooking
skills of course i know anna vibes with
that uh modesty cleanliness easy going
family behind her i like that family is
really important guys um where is proper
hijab i like that uh the brother uh
proper in a capital al-islam because
proper is something that you know hijab
isn't just a headscarf and you know so
on and so forth okay
uh proper dean with proper hijab we got
this again if there's no proper deen i'm
not looking at other things
okay just going to wrap it up now sober
and chaste
has a solid foundation of knowledge
regarding quran sunnah and hadith
taqwa agreeability good manners
we got women has no issue with cooking
and cleaning that's key anh said in an
episode um or a reaction video that we
did like
you know it's not you're not a servant
but you should be cooking and cleaning
and and serving to your men like i don't
see what's difficult about that
um
and a man
has has the roof over your head so it is
what it is caring and supportive yet
also takes care of her own duties
dean fitness etc
last two we are looks youth beauty
submissiveness
and friendliness and for the last one we
got piety modesty and dress and conduct
this is key
uh not being so loud and good looks
in that order
so y'all y'all could see the pattern
[Music]
and with that being said
let's open this up for uh open
discussion you want to answer the you
want me to do last one ten minutes
um if you're gonna do the last one man i
gotta dip because y'all i'll wrap it up
real quick bro
what are red flags for women to never
marry or to make you want to divorce
them okay we have disrespect
dishonorable behaviors they don't pray
or don't privatize a dean promiscuity
masculinity oh yeah that's that's
masculine is a red flag with women at
least in an unhealthy amount playing too
much games haram past haram posts
two phase behaviors not on deen
rebellious
we are placing an ideology on the same
level or even above islam
excessive consumerism lack of iman
lack of empathy
manliness someone wrote in quotation
marks anna's gonna like this we can have
friends of the opposite gender
if you guys know you know uh big feet i
don't know okay cool that's it that's a
red flag for you i guess that has
narcissistic behavior male friends
hiding phone no intimacy poor intimacy
this is key guys
um extra marital affairs blasphemy
abusive toxic these things are haram
anyway but
the fact that these are red flags show
that you know muslims are having these
today um so we all got to step up as men
and women support secularism all right
last 20 seconds
feminist
no dean
we got backbiting that's huge men and
women has pics of herself
showing off on social media this is this
is you like that
free mixes with non-men
a career woman
wants a more expensive wedding
over a marriage
not wearing hijab okay last one
let me get a good one
bossy
meaning never ask your opinion just
tells you what we are going to do
okay guys
we are done now as you all can see
it's super simple like as men there's a
pattern and we all
kind of want the same thing and we don't
want the same thing so it's very simple
for us man
all right thank you for responsible
about it
okay last question before we open up to
public
abdul says my local imam has had a
khutba where describing marriage is
strong if there is respect and trust
hundred percent there's a there's a
a by the name of uh
uh
ali i believe from the uk
he made a merit series please check that
out guys a lot of gems i'm just going to
change the
thing to subscribers only now for the
chat just give me one sec
live
and i just want to add that these are
things that will kind of
you know get you married to someone
these are not things that will i mean
some of them will but not all of them
are going to sustain your marriage right
allah says in the quran that he put
between a man and a woman or between
husband and wife passionate love
and mercy you guys need to passionately
love each other and be merciful with
each other because you're not always
going to be the best version of yourself
tonight did i cut off for a second i
need to be making and love every single
day
but she's on a period bro
i mean you could still be making
possibilities passionate love bro yeah
bro doesn't mean you have to
you have to what's it called the
penetrate
that is very true that is very true you
can penetrate our mind every day bro
regardless of period
okay
hakeem about time lol okay oh we got
we already got like 10 questions come on
now
what if her sister says yes to the
condition that she wants to have kids
though
oh on the condition that she wants to
have kids though she won't she won't
have kids
i like
all of us unanimously not what man
doesn't want to start a family exactly
i don't know so much
is it wise to blindly trust a man
especially in the society we live in
today i understand that trust is key
okay uh ladies if he says he's gonna
marry you soon or you know just i i
wanna you know get to know you first and
then i'll marry you
he probably doesn't want to marry you
he's not he's not taking you seriously
i'm i'm saying it as it is
the only person we should blindly trust
is
prophet sallallahu alaihi we're saying
you see that the things the thing is
it's not even blind to trust cause what
is blind blind is misguided right if you
trust someone it has to be a guided
decision if you
there's a difference between trusting
someone and and being an idiot being
gullible right if a random man comes up
to me and said he's like you know um
take this briefcase and go deliver to
that man and you know i'll give you a
million dollars you know i'm not gonna
trust him i'm not gonna like that's
that's stupid so if a man comes to you
like fraud says and he's like oh i'm
gonna marry you i just want to get to
know you and like let's go out uh two
times a week and come over and
then you're just being dumb if you
listen to that point you say listen go
to my father or get the hell out of my
face
okay let's go quickly uh shahzad asks
what is the best days to get made i
think you know the sona is to get
married as young as possible if you are
able to and you have the ability to get
married if you can't then fast so um i
would say if you are able to get married
100 i'd say once you hit puberty yeah
exactly
no is that legal in a lot of states and
provinces probably not but
everyone's going to hit puberty at
different ages bro i didn't if you would
until i was like 16 17. the sister that
asked uh
won't have kids she forgot to add that
she would be willing to be your co-wife
would that change oh yeah yeah
100
100 percent she also doesn't need to be
like if i marry one woman the standards
for her are gonna be so much higher than
if i have multiple women of course
okay having kids with your man is one of
the biggest ways to bless up if she
ain't about that jump straight out the
window
okay feel like there are no real men
left only small boys and big bodies
few very few that are husband material
uh it goes both ways sis there's a lot
of women out here that are not wi-fi
material but there's no point it's not
conducive to any type of progress to
talk about what this what the problem is
let's talk about the solution you know
inshallah we can provide that and
there's a lot of resources to show you
what we should be as men and women um
and yeah that's all i gotta say
can you make a video about how a man can
improve himself islamically and be more
desirable for women
we got you
we got you check out our show
the intimacy series that we made with uh
brother gabriel you'll find a couple
gems there for now
okay
guys we got uh three more minutes
go back to that question go back to that
question
which one
the one
just had to screenshot it so we can
re revision
okay
uh how many rakaas are in wudu every
ex-muslim fails this question very funny
um what's the verdict on women who are
considered less feminine by societal
standards how would you address that
issue
anything
what do they mean by what was the
verdict like
like what do we do about it
less feminine by societal standards uh
well i don't really care about societal
standards i care more about islamic
sharia standards because societal
societal standards for women in terms of
let's say dress code i'm just giving an
example completely low like berserk i'm
not even going to talk about that so
when a woman even dresses three quarters
naked she's dressed modestly because all
women are half naked so let's not talk
about societal standards at least living
out here in the west
so islamic standards we can talk about
that
next does her phone count as private
property without guardianship over it if
you trust her why not
oh this is a good question does the
phone count as private property private
property exactly though
because what i believe is because women
have a right to own their own property
and stuff so um
uh yeah there's a simple answer there's
a simple answer
do you pay the phone bill
you pay the phone bill then
you have
you have all the right to
put the messages and all that yeah i i
don't i don't think it's a matter of who
owns it i think it's a matter of you
know like do you trust your wife do not
trust your wife i don't think you should
cause issues with having to search
through it if you suspect suspect
something okay but if not yes
don't look for trouble thank you for the
addition bro
okay two minutes guys
i'm 20 and have opened myself to
potentially getting married or possibly
getting married insha'allah what advice
do you have for young muslims entering
the marriage market
know what you want know what to look for
know what to watch out for get your
father involved please and be patient
yeah please be patient yeah and listen
listen to your dad if he's being berserk
like he's not from this place he's not
from where we're from then don't listen
to him but if he's being straight up and
being like i don't like this about him
he has an awful vibe i would say listen
to your father
yeah
and please be patient don't just accept
the first one
why don't you eat soup bro
get out of here bro get out of here go
back to tik tok man
okay so sarah sends a super chat
uh
for that by the way sis are you guys
salafis
meaning do you follow quran and sunnah
only
i wouldn't i wouldn't i mean speaking on
myself i would not say i'm salafi i
would say
yeah you definitely follow quran yeah
and i i hate that you know there's
there's a whole
deviance between what asafi actually
means today versus
if you take the literal meaning which
means you just follow you know the salaf
which is the pious prejudices so it's
like it's like bro what do you want us
to say we're stuck between a rock and a
hard place we follow the quran and the
sunnah thousand percent
to the end um may allah guide us to
continue to do that um yeah in terms of
you know all of these sects and
different things i don't know you know
yeah
nadeem what are your opinions on a woman
not being too close to her family versus
a man not being close to his
hmm they're both islamically wrong
yeah
they both need to fix up
yeah
i will say though um by nature
the way by fitra
women are more susceptible to influence
this is a fact this is this is
undisputed
um therefore
it would go in my logic
that follows that if a woman
is not too close to her family
it's more of a red flag to me than a man
not being close to his
okay
go back to um the super chat real quick
yeah
so i wanted to say something so we are
um
yeah okay so
it's all about the quran and sunnah
right and and at the end of the day
we're all muslim
there's no point to adhere to
a certain section
we're all muslim we follow the quran
that's it
any other stuff that you see
it's
to say that it's islam i don't know that
that'd be like
i'd say that's almost kind of like
what's it called vida innovation
you know it's it's a form of that it's a
form of innovation where it's like look
maybe perhaps you could look into
[Music]
let's say it's insane right and then
let's say they have something or
there might be some wisdom there might
be like a little nugget of of gold but
at the end of the day you take it as you
would you don't take it as your ikea you
don't take it as you islam you take it
as just that grain of salt it's like
when you you read something
philosophical you read something of the
kuffar where it's like hmm that's
actually pretty intelligent there's a
lot of wisdom behind that you don't take
that as like the end-all be-all it's
like okay now i'm taking all my beliefs
from this no this is just something that
you take
as a great assault at the end of the day
you should be muslim
and you should be only doing the quran
and sunnah and that's pretty much it
all right guys we're gonna do one last
chat
super chat's gonna stick out if it's not
normal chat uh we'll put on for another
minute
the youtube brothers have anything else
to say while we wait for that chat
i wanted to go back to that one sister
who who asked that question
about the verdict
because
we didn't really answer i just missed
like i didn't understand what she said
and then we kind of moved on so i don't
want to give her nothing
but i would say as you said islamic
standards when it comes to not being
feminine
islam doesn't really discuss being
feminine
but it does discuss a woman obeying her
husband and everything so
when it comes to the dean as long as she
you know understands that the her
husband is in charge he has final say
then like that he should be good uh and
the the verdict on that i would say
generally stay away from women like that
because they're i feel like they're just
going to cause problems in the marriage
yeah and if the woman is like super
disagreeable yeah
that's that's a big no
yeah that's a hard pass
yeah yeah hamdullah we got one final
question from brother nadim who was a
member so we're going to answer this who
is someone you are most looking forward
to featuring on your podcast even if it
out if it is out of reach so nadeem uh
shout out to you for becoming a member
today and asking the most
questions and chatting compared to
everyone anyone else so you you
definitely got mvp for this
i'll let the other two go first i say
muhammad's job yeah i was gonna say the
same thing
both of you yeah
[Music]
i can't i can't even think of one person
bro
i've been really high on the sources so
yeah we already had amazon i can't think
of just one person you know what i was
looking forward to be honest to for
azerbaijan
all right all right guys jazakallah here
for tuning in
until next time next friday same time 10
30 a.m est
please smash that like button get us to
1 000 likes on this live stream and we
will air a longer teaser trailer
uh for the frazzle hobby episodes this
sunday uh but in the meantime you can
check out the shorts that i uploaded
this morning
[Music]
there's another thing too it's it's the
perseverance aspect too like we're more
willing to stick through with things
that we set out with an intention it's
impossible to have empathy for others if
you're not patient so my love bless you
for that first of all i agree with the
fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
yo rami
this is the only time i'm ever gonna
stop the the patron
outro because we got a super chat bro
yeah i just saw it
salam i read someone asking about being
desirable for women personally i think
we should focus on being acceptable to
allah his creation will follow i agree
yeah 100
no uh no issues with that jazakallahu
[Music]
it's like if they're affecting you more
than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel inshallah
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]